president trunk confirming a large-scale
immigration crackdown will begin this
weekend major cities are preparing for
ice raids on Sunday
targeting thousands of illegal
immigrants the president defending the
operation people come into our country
illegally we're taking them out legally
what the Democrats should be doing now
is they should be changing the loopholes
they should be changing asylum we have
millions of people standing on line
waiting to become citizens of this
country it's not fair that somebody
walks to cross the line and now they've
become citizens
nothing to be secret about if the word
gets out it gets out we're taking them
out by the thousands Democrats are
furious with the president's plans Nancy
Pelosi now being criticized for giving
illegal immigrants this advice a nice
deportation warrant is not the same as a
search warrant if that is the only
document ice brings to a home raid
agents do not have the legal right to
enter a home if ice agents don't have a
warrant warrant signed by a judge a
person may refuse to open the door and
let them in Joy Behar also causing
controversy by comparing the upcoming
raids to what happened in Nazi Germany
Trump intends to move forward with his
immigration raids targeting migrant
families this weekend I thought it was
supposed to be gangs coming from these
places not families with children he's
gonna you know raid these people's
houses and what-have-you and they'd
really reminiscent of Nazi Germany just
saying wow so this is like an intense
moment so Jesse let's just start with
the Pelosi you know advice to people who
are here illegally that they don't have
to respond to a simple immigration
warrant that they need a search warrant
to open the door what are you thinking
so you have Congress women saying don't
follow and comply with the law that
Congress passed everything that's
happening here is completely illegal if
you have an illegal immigrant crossing
the border they get caught by Border
Patrol you
you process them they get a hearing in
front of an immigration judge if they
apply for asylum or if they just want to
come here for work the judge says yes
you can stay or no and issues a
deportation hearing proceeding then ice
will come because they do interior
enforcement to a house apprehend and
deport that's the law that Congress
passed years ago the executive branch is
enforcing that law and a judge is
signing off on everything so you have
the executive judicial and legislative
branches all working together
harmoniously but you have Democrats
saying don't follow the laws of our
country they want American citizens to
follow the laws but they don't want
illegal aliens so at this point you have
to think do they want any enforcement
they don't want it in the interior they
don't want it at the border they don't
want you to have to stay in the country
that you are and apply when you get
there they don't want you to taint if
you commit a crime in a sanctuary city
they don't want let ice know about it
they don't even want the federal
government to ask you a question are you
a US citizen but what they do want they
want to give you an American job they
want to give you a driver's license
in-state college tuition and they want
to give you free health insurance so at
this point the Democrats are the party
of open borders and that's just a fact
just a quick question on this isn't it
the case that she's saying here is the
law as it's written so she's not saying
violate the law she's saying follow the
law no if you are issued a deportation
order from a judge right in America you
have to follow that order right okay
Dana
so what we're also seeing is that
Hillary Clinton as well as Pelosi you're
saying hey this is heartless people go
to church on Sunday and you're breaking
down doors
oh is that that's really oh okay all
right God's got it so neglecting to
enforce the law for a couple of decades
on these enforcement orders means that
this problem just gets harder and unless
America is going to say okay then
everybody's here illegally you could
stay if we're gonna say that and we
should have that debate and then the
laws would have to change I don't think
anybody's actually saying that the fact
that we have so many illegal immigrants
here that
hurting people who want to immigrate
here legally the number of stories of
people who are stuck in the process who
are stuck in the in the paperwork
because there's not enough resources to
figure out how to get them here legally
we need people to come here we need
people to come and work and to want to
raise their families here I would also
say that like what Joy Behar said it's
so atrocious because Jews were targeted
because of who they were not because of
what they had done right that what that
was these were citizens of Germany they
were paying taxes and they were that
comparing again comparing Nazi Germany
to this is really bad President Trump
also said today we are going we're
focused on criminals as much as we can
and I believe that because the
Department of Homeland Security is under
such extreme scrutiny and they've
telegraphed for six weeks that these
raids are coming that imagine how
everyone's going to be out and about in
these cities ready to film anything to
try to catch anything that would make it
look like they are being insensitive and
it is gonna be heart-wrenching people
are here for a long time they have ties
but if they've committed a crime in the
United States and they have a
deportation order and the President of
the United States decides to execute on
those orders then I think they have to
follow the law for as hard as it might
be to watch it is actually what needs to
be done and the fact that we haven't
done it for decades means it just gets
worse if the longer we don't do it by
the way Greg so yesterday we had the
news that the president was not going to
try continue his efforts to put a
question about citizenship Susan's
citizenship status on the census yes
so is this now just a political step to
say hey Democrats you better get on
board and start doing what I want and
the illegal immigrants are the ones who
are going to feel the brunt of this over
the weekend well before I go any further
I'd like to be sworn in no I'd want to
be sworn in damn it's okay to the point
about yesterday or whatever day that was
I loved his solution using databases and
we already had it totally destroys all
the objections about it violating this
or filing that and it may be more
accurate to answering the census
question that's pretty badass I have to
say he's not President Trump
he's president MacGyver he figured out a
way to solve the problem with the tools
that he had and only somebody who's been
in business understands this politician
sat there and focused on this problem
for so long and he says I'll just go
around back and fix this myself his he
is solving these problems using two key
movers in human nature one of them is
fairness and the other is incentives
fairness people who did it the right way
people who waited in line it is not fair
to cut in line it is that everybody
understands that especially minorities
who have come from other countries who
waited in line the process matters
because then everybody's treated fairly
that's human nature incentives what he's
doing right now is predicated on the
Republican gift for disincentives word
gets out that we're going to deport
people who are there illegally
disincentivizes people from coming here
it's the opposite of waving caravans
through so these are two things that
human beings understand fairness and
incentives these are two things that the
Democrats can't get into their thick
skulls and that's why they're losing the
American public and they're devouring
themselves and now I would like to be
sworn in but one of the questions about
this is if you are going after people
who are undocumented and haven't shown
up for court dates is it possible that
you then sweep up people who really have
been living here families together done
nothing wrong I mean in fact paying
taxes and working but they're gonna get
swept up in all the activity this
weekend I think that's true true and
unrelated if you mean swept up but they
are the subject of final deportation
orders then that's the whole point
and and to respond to what both of you
guys were saying I think that the outcry
over the enforcement of the existing
laws ignores the fact that there are
built-in safety features within the
process itself the final deportation
order means that all appeals have been
exhausted even if the immigrant just
reserves or waves or reserves the right
to appeal that automatically stays the
entire proceeding there and more safety
features built-in so are we calling into
question the
order the judges judgment are we calling
into question the policies the 90 days
that ice has to then deport like if so
then let's change it Congress people or
voters or what else do our tax dollars
pay for there are estimates of hundreds
of thousands if not 1 million that are
here with final deportation orders
million for us yes for us to ignore that
or for us to pick and choose what laws
we want to enforce why then would we why
wouldn't we pick and choose every other
law so when you say that it's up to us
to basically exemplify and model what's
going on like absolutely because what
other message are we sending and I would
think that it would be incumbent upon
all of us to appreciate that because the
rest of us that are here should know
that our government does prioritize
enforcing laws because otherwise
shouldn't I be scared 24 hours a day
that anything can happen as a Democrat
said oh no no no but not this one yeah
it's a Sunday yeah no thank you